welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the boys season two ended with
a twist
very few saw coming maybe because anyone
who was about to say it out loud got
their heads popped by jeff bezos this
season's mystery skull exploder who
murdered cia deputy director raynor at
least 14 people at a congressional
hearing including a congressman a new
member of the seven shockwave former
vots cso jonah vogelbaum and others
was not church of the collective head
alastair adana who no longer has one
nor vot headstand edgar who still has
his for now
and might have been involved in this
plot nor telekinetic body
imploder cindy nor beardy apologies to
that extra but it was confirmed to be
congresswoman victoria newman
nomad ickyvicky as i'm going to call her
the aoc inspired politician who kept
reappearing throughout the season who
seemed fundamentally
opposite from whatever the hedpopper's
motives were looking like but as the
obvious target who miraculously managed
to survive that attack
probably should have been looked at more
closely and as i re-watched this season
this show did an amazing job concealing
this
with clues just easy enough to overlook
but in retrospect all line up pretty
neatly so i'm gonna break down
every newman clue we missed and look at
her possible next moves in the boys
season 3 which will begin production
next year so throughout the season
newman was publicly accusing vaught of
corruption and conspiracy
after reports of the company's use of
compound v to create
supes she ended up in a social media war
with homelander and stormfront the two
of them stirring up fear over supe
terrorists a growing threat that would
necessitate the need for compound v
and a threat that reached its peak at
the congressional hearing in which
newman brought in vogelbaum to testify
against vot before this happened
in the aftermath of that attack the
secretary of defense told newman that
the government would be distributing
compound v to law enforcement which is
good news for stan edgar who confirmed
this season that he is
all about pharma driven profit make
compound v a consumer product to drive
up
vaught stock value edgar and newman must
therefore be in cahoots
working this debate from both sides with
both having plausible deniabilities
since both anti-bot government leaders
died and a member of the bots
seven died madonna was killed because he
had more dirt on bot and it was his
colts meticulous record keeping that
allowed stormfront to be outed as a nazi
and stormfront was instrumental to that
fear campaign to get bought on the
streets but presumably stormfront's
downfall forced
vot to re-evaluate its strategy to
instead blame the head pops on her but
both edgar and newman remain in power
with newman poised to be elected into
higher office
see newman's name comes from victor
newman in the boys comics aka vic the
veep
the airheaded vice president controlled
by vaught as a puppet and eventually
becomes president
the show's counterpart icky vicky let's
make that sticky
is also apparently working in bot's
interest but with a more devious and
deadly agenda so i'm assuming that will
be the threat of season three
the coup that rayner worried about
coming true with newman's political fame
rising and rising
all the way to the white house baby
where she would be cloaked in immense
power
to help vaught dominate pharmaceuticals
and secure a windfall for edgar
and as a super super the power to pop
heads i don't like she'd be that worried
about out of control soups all over the
world so the two things we know about
newman's head popping ability
are one she requires direct line of
sight and two shortly after the attack
her
eyes briefly roll over white maybe like
a firearm discharging an empty shell a
reset
so let us apply these two rules to her
past appearances starting with the
congress attack at the end of episode
seven so the first head to pop was that
of newman's fellow
congressman whom newman was looking
directly at
smarter were to begin with a congressman
instead of vogelbaum because that makes
this attack look more like a political
assassination with a lot of people
just caught in the crossfire newman was
also probably looking at vogelbaum for
this pop and then there's this quick
close-up of her in which you can barely
see newman's eyes guarding from one
angle to another
corresponding with two pops one of them
shockwave newman then remains frozen
transfixed on the crowd but not out of
paralytic fear as we thought but focused
death stares then mallory grabs her but
right then you can almost make out a
white glare in newman's eyes
that could be the recharge could just be
the light from the window but when
mallory and newman make their way for
the door the pops pause briefly
until newman's chief of staff lisa but
lisa doesn't die
until newman first turns around to look
at her
that right there is smoking gun proof
and then after running back to lisa
newman sits back in one of the seats
wide eyes
eyes darting around the room just to get
in as many more head pops as she can
man and speaking of going out with a
bang with a delicious carbonated
beverage thank you to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories yet
it tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from
this one is pina colada a true tropical
delight
every sip giving you the energy to do a
million
limbo dips check out bang on instagram
you can get
25 off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including sweet tea keto coffee flavors
star blast is a good one purple guava
pear you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self if you like the boys be a bang
boy take a bang take a sip
be a boy thanks again to paying energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
now jumping back to newman's first
strike against rayner in episode one
ma'am your nose
now in those background shots there is
quite a bit of movement
across the river behind raynor on the
sidewalk by the street on the other side
of the parking lot there are a few
parked cars that newman could easily be
sitting in with an audio amplifying
microphone you know like they have on
the side of football fields but the real
clue comes in the edit
how do you know who can do that no one
immediate cut to
look i have a daughter i'm worried about
super terrorists too
yeah that editing answered eminem's
question victoria newman was one who did
this
also it's worth noting stan edgar is
often watching newman on tv
here he is carefully observing how she
is playing this and then he watches her
again in episode three
my dad always used to say where there's
smoke there's fire so
vaught lied to us about compound v what
else are they lying to us about and then
in episode five newman speaks at the
rally
bot has all the money and the power
and we have no offense ejection
but after homelanders war crime
how can i stay quiet and still look my
daughter in the eyes yeah
look my daughter in the eyes interesting
choice of words
and then when homelander crashes a rally
her eyes stay glued to homelander
like she hardly blinks once she is ready
to pop his head if she needs to
now later that episode we see the first
of stormfront's newman memes a parody of
the photo they tend to use for aoc memes
superheroes invade my personal space
kind of the way her telekinesis
literally invades others personal space
inside their skulls
episode 7 opens with another one of
those memes an image of newman with a
target on her head
reading target acquired ironic
considering in her mind it is likely a
similar bullseye on the heads of others
but this episode butcher correctly
worries about newman's corruption
congress please what a bunch of corrupt
[ __ ]
say uh but it was newman who fought for
a higher up whistleblower at vot to be
dragged out into the light
if we're gonna take a shot at the king
we can't [ __ ] miss
we know someone who might know the full
picture
who was it like you said
we're gonna have to trust each other yet
mallory refused to disclose this contact
to newman right in this moment otherwise
newman could have totally taken out
bogobon before the hearing and then
after that massacre in episode eight
newman keeps up the act to probe singer
to test
how much of a political obstacle he will
be to her yeah we know we were there
remember
covered in my chief of staff's brains
look there was no terrorist it was
vaught it's a [ __ ]
coup a bunch of their guys died too to
cover their own tracks for the record
i agree with you and notice newman's
reaction when the secretary
says doses are going for five million a
pop pentagon's got a big order in yeah
she was looking directly at him but him
saying the word
pop nearly triggered her so she was like
oh i gotta look away
kudos to the boys season two for hiding
this so well because it was such an
amazing reveal that made going back
through the season so rewarding i
suggest you re-watch as well and you can
discuss all things nerdy with me on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patreon at
patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
at eavos
following the rockstars thank you for
watching now i gotta celebrate a
wonderful season with a bang
[Music]
you